so obviously 13 years since the original
film and it was making me wonder along
the way what would you say was I guess
kind of the low point where you might
have thought to yourself like wow we
really might not make this happen and
then ultimately how did you overcome
that and see it through to fruition
that's a really interesting question I
mean we we did all our performance
capture we started in September of 17.
we did performance capture for a year
and a half then we did over a year of
live action photography I think the
lowest point was you know when we got
all got locked down the whole world got
locked down everything was up for grabs
all of our priorities suddenly didn't
mean what we thought they meant you know
and recovering and coming out of that
and getting back into production and
then working for a subsequent couple of
years on a film that might not have
theaters to play in you know and then
slowly seeing the industry around me
recovering as I'm finishing the film and
then building up Optimus and confidence
that there will be theaters to play the
film in
um you know and I think had we come out
any earlier there would have been no
hope for profitability right now we're a
bit on the cusp right because we haven't
come fully back yet we're at about 80
percent
um you know so well what the heck we
just have to be better we just have to
be a better movie
I've got a lot of faith that a lot of
people are going to prioritize seeing
this in the next couple of weeks I was
very curious about the writing process
on this because I know it was important
to you to have the screen placed for the
future films written out before going
into production on this so why was that
important and do you think that all film
series would benefit from that
development process or is that specific
to Avatar well I don't think it's
specific to Avatar I mean if you look at
my model was what Peter Jackson did with
the Lord of the Rings which was which
was a crazy bet in its time and really
we you know hats off to that that they
took that chance to to launch on all
three of those films but he had the
books mapped out so he could always show
the actors what they needed to know
about their character Arc so I felt I
had to do the same thing I had to play
this as if the books already existed so
the only way for us to do that was to
you know write all the scripts and let
the actors read all the scripts and see
where their characters were going and
what it all meant you know not that
that's actable in the moment but I think
it's something that the actress could
work into their preparation for their
characters so they knew to okay we're
going to come in and film this in
bite-sized chunks not necessarily in
sequence we're going to be shooting
parts of two parts of three parts of
four on any given day that's a challenge
but it's no different a challenge than
let's say if you're working on a limited
series and you've got a home set that's
going to be seen across six hours it's
no different I mean I'm not saying
there's anything unique about this but I
felt that it was the right way to
approach it with the actors and also to
let them see where it's all going so
they're they're properly motivated and
enthused because the story is a quarker
by the time we get down by the time we
get down to four and five if we're so
lucky you know knock wood to get that
far you know which is obviously driven
by market forces we have to be
successful I heard you use that term in
another interview and I am curious
because I think you were specifically
talking about film four what is it that
makes it a corker what is it about that
film that makes it stand out from what
we'll have seen I can't tell you the
details but all I can say is that when I
turn in the script for two the studio
gave me three pages of notes
and when I turned in the script for
three they gave me a page of notes so I
was getting better when I turned in the
script for four the studio executive
creative executive over over the films
wrote me an email that said holy [ __ ]
and and I said well where are the notes
and she said those are the notes
because it just goes it it kind of goes
nuts in a way that like in a good way
right I think you know what it's about
and then no no you don't I believe I
have all the faith in the world to you
and speaking of that I hope I get to
make that film is what I'm saying I'm
rooting for it and I believe in it I
can't imagine these movies without you
at the helm and I know you've previously
said that one day you might hand the
directing Reigns over to someone else so
what would you need to see in a future
director to ensure to you that yes this
person can you know like handle my baby
and this gigantic production that like
really I can't picture very many people
on this planet being able to kind of
orchestrate and conduct I think there
are a lot of good a lot of good
filmmakers out there and a lot of good
filmmakers that understand how to do CG
and animation and World building and all
that sort of thing I think that that
what I would look for was somebody that
is willing to be humble before the
specific craft of how you make one of
these films because it's taken us
at this point 15 16 years to figure it
out and we're still learning day to day
so it would take time to transfer that
that knowledge but I think you know with
respect to uh or in respect to the
studio that that's writing these massive
checks to create this world this
persistent world I think it's good for
for us to have at least some kind of a
plan to hand that over you know I mean
nobody lives forever and I might get
sick somebody in my family might get
sick you know I might have to step back
and and uh I don't want that to be the
case obviously I want to I want to do
all five of them myself I think it would
be good to have some kind of a plan in
place to be able to turn the reins over
well whether it's you whether you're
handing that plan over to someone else I
have faith congratulations yet again
thanks